idea of classes to classify this series
we have it's empty space which we've
been doing for a long time in New York
Miller theater and Cooper Union in years
past basically the idea is to try to
give the audience an idea of the context
and the character of the piece in a way
which would inform their listening
without guarding it you know there
there's a whole generation of music
education videos or programs
Leonard burns on pioneered them with
young people's concerts Michael Tilson
Thomas is a series of the San Francisco
a lot of those programs try to explain
the piece take a Beethoven symphony they
don't fix it and to which everybody
knows and try to explain how it's put
together so it's as if you had a video
on auto mechanics and someone took the
car apart they showed you here is the
here the Pistons and here is the wheel
and here's that tire and here's the
starter and here are the electronics
this is the transmission and this is how
works and teach you so basic physics on
why the car moves so that you can learn
something about why the car actually
moves and works and how it works so
that's one way of doing it we don't do
that what we do is something different
we don't try to simplify a complex
subject like music theory I'm using four
which is a lot of technical vocabulary
which most people don't know once upon a
time everybody went to you know candle
lessons in the middle class audience and
they knew a little bit about Korean
music sort of and they could play the
piano so they knew that every mean major
and minor or you could use some
technical vocabulary that's gone you
know most people grow up with pop music
and rock music they they play they do it
by ear the improvised didn't only theory
they don't lingo so what do you want
talking about their educated people I'm
not talking about the things that they
are interested in that connect to music
so we talk about the politics of the
period in which the period the piece was
written we'll talk about the
relationship to literature to art to the
problems in this composition and what
the piece did for the composer
biographically where it comes from in
the composer's lifetime what their
relationship between music and other
issues they can be philosophical they
can be political you'll be poetic also
what's innovative so in the case of a
very well-known piece like this Symphony
you want to show a little bit how the
piece is put together in order to show
why Beethoven is special what has made
this piece so famous and what's the key
to its popularity why do people think
the piece represents victory why do you
think the piece represents something
that's military why did Peter
killer the composer who is a humorous
narrate a football game you know as
using the first movement of the
Beethoven v as a soundtrack now why do
the Allies use the opening bars as a
symbol of victory why did this piece
become an icon so you do explain a
little bit about how the pieces put
together but you talk more about
thinking about ways of thinking about
the piece because you do want it tell
the audience how to listen
I'm always offended by program
explanations or nodes that sort of say
well here comes a trumpet tune and then
it changes key and then there's a
variation so the poor listeners of
looking for what someone has taught her
or him to look at so as if I take a boat
around Manhattan instead of leaving me
to look around to see I might look at
the sky I might look at the water and
said I'm looking they told me there's
the Empire State buildings I'm waiting
for the Empire State Building to arrive
then they go around the bend and they
tell me whether it's the United Nations
I'm waiting for the United Nations
arrive well I might as well stay at home
you know I haven't seen anything on my
own
notice that what you don't want to turn
music listen to tourism tourism is a
fraud you buy a little guidebook and it
tells you go see the Eiffel Tower in
Paris that's all they see the best thing
to do is throw the guidebook away and
just go for a walk
no discover the place for yourself so
what we try to help the person discover
stuff and think about stuff without
giving them answers